candid truth welcome to candid truth
we're going to talk about the truth and
we're GNA get candid with it I'm so
excited about tonight's show because one
of my favorite documentary filmmakers of
all time has agreed to do a show with us
and it's just going to be so cool Bart
saell creator of a Funny Thing Happened
on the Way to the Moon powerful
documentary I saw it I think 2012 2013
and I've shared it everywhere we're
going to start this off with an intro to
that if you've never heard of it this is
going to be an eye openening show for
you so stick around watch the intro and
we're going to get into an awesome
interview with Bart there we go
[Music]
we
since the beginning of recorded history
the human race has been at war first
with members of their own family then
their fellow countrymen and finally
Nations at large yet Perhaps the
starting ground for all these conflicts
lays somewhere deeper within the very
character of The Human Condition in the
dark Untouchable crevices of the human
heart it is said that the first iniquity
of Free Will began even before the
maiden pilgrimage from the embryo
preceding the very creation of the Earth
itself in the forlife of souls in the
Heavenly Realms the dawn of warfare some
believe was initiated by a fallen angel
whose trespass against God was
pride in ancient Babylonia in an age so
long ago that the exact Millennium
remains in question the Tower of Babel
began
construction it was to be the single
greatest achievement of the human race a
tower so tall that its Summit would
reach the heavens and by it prove to the
world that their race was Superior it
would be God's irony that it would never
be finished time passed Nations fell a
machine age emerged and once again the
Ingenuity of the species which held
dominion over all others unveiled what
was at the time the most mon Monumental
accomplishment ever imagined the largest
machine yet constructed an automation so
Mammoth and so revered even before its
first demonstration that its only
befitting name was
Titanic on April 10th 1912 it set
sail it was boasted to be the ship that
God himself could not
sink it would be God's irony that the
very element that was meant to keep it
afloat would cause it to sink water
frozen water in the form of an iceberg
not even one voyage did it
complete and then the next age embarked
into the annals of human history perhaps
the last Age The Space Age competition
for Victor was
unparalleled powerful Nations spent
billions in unabashed rivalry to outdo
the other the Soviet Union launched the
first orbiting satellite the first
animal the first man they had logged
500% more hours in space than the United
States and in June of 1969 they launched
an unmanned probe to the Moon to
retrieve the first soil sample from
another world just one month before
Apollo 11 that's how close the race was
had their unmanned probe Not Crash
landed into the Luna surface the first
moon rock brought back to Earth would
have been by the Soviet Union Richard
Nixon president at the time had this to
say about the latest work of the human
hand it is the greatest week since
creation the greatest event since the
laying of the foundation of the Seas
since the origin of the universe itself
since the design and formation of the
delicate human eye through which all
these things are perceived was a flying
machine with its two passengers landing
on its closest Celestial neighbor and
returning from where it came
perhaps again God's irony lies somewhere
within this great boast of
humankind the building of the tallest
tower for the sole purpose of standing
Out Among the races was never finished
the machine that was so great that it
was said to be Untouchable by even God
never completed its first
voyage and finally the crowning
achievement of humankind the greatest
boast of the species the event in human
history most associated with pride in
our own
accomplishments landing on the
moon 20 years later and years behind
schedule the same space program couldn't
put into Earth orbit a telescope with a
lens that focused and yet two decades
earlier a mission 100 times more
complicated worked on its first
occasion with close scrutiny of the
motives of the zealous Nixon
Administration a Critical examination of
the entire entirely government
controlled press coverage and newly
discovered footage of the crew of Apollo
11 staging part of their mission we wish
to detail what may come to be the
greatest government conspiracy of all
time A Funny Thing Happened on the Way
to the
moon and now I want to introduce Bart
saell thank you so much for coming on
our show it's man you've been an
encourage agement uh for years to me and
like I said your documentary has been so
eye openening that it's the it's my
go-to like when
somebody has questions about the
moonland I'm like you gotta watch funny
thing happen away the Moon and you'll
see for sure so thank you so much for
coming on
man sure Mikey how you doing doing good
man how are
you yeah not too bad hanging in there I
wanted to ask you like what was your
kind of moment of Awakening because for
me I remember I started seeing these
little videos like um Illuminati hand
signs from rap stars and stuff like that
and for me I was like okay I can see
that some of these people have sold
their soul for fame you know it was
offered to Jesus some people are taking
that offer but I couldn't see like a big
picture I couldn't see like a grand
conspiracy
until God literally knocked the blinders
off of my eyes it was December 2011
stood me up out of my seat and suddenly
I could it was like the veil dropped I
could see through you know major
corporate logos had these Pagan and
satanic symbols in them and I was
starting to see uh a lot of this
symbolism in movies and cartoons and
kids stuff but the moon landing was
something that was planted in my head
even in high school this is crazy maybe
you maybe you remember this but when I
was in high school in the early
2000s I think I remember Fox playing a a
documentary or something where they were
actually showing some of these anomalies
like Shadows going the wrong way and
this and that and it was on Fox
television but it was like a one-time
thing so for me my Awakening was really
kind of December
2011 what what got you into this because
I know you were a filmmaker you had all
these dreams and aspirations but
something had to have gotten your
attention about
this well so much to say
there I grew up believing that the
moonlandings are real and probably more
so uh I had a shrine of Apollo 11
pictures in my bedroom as a kid I was
four years old to sleep in bed when it
allegedly happened but my father was a
officer in the Air Force and got a VIP
package of these Color Prints and
wherever we moved every two years that
was a center part of my bedroom this
collection of men on the moon and
I assumed they were real and thought it
was glorious to the point of having a
shrine in my
house and then when I saw a TV program
at age 14 that's after seeing them at
least once a day for 10 years or 3, was
that age
14 yeah I mean the event allegedly
happened uh when I was four and I don't
remembered I was asleep in bed so from
the age of 4 to 14 I had a shrine of
apoll 11 pictures on my wall so if I saw
them only once a day and I probably saw
them three times a day but that would be
3,650 times I saw these pictures at
three times a day that's over 10,000 and
then at age
14 I watch TV program of a former NASA
contractor with ey security clearance
who said they did not go to the Moon
they cannot go to the moon and therefore
like a good poker player they bluffed
and I'm an open-minded 14-year-old
uh and I'm like sure I've never thought
of that let me go back and take a look
at these pictures and sure enough I
started seeing what appeared to be fake
backdrops and in the original prints
which I had the soil was a brown color
and the backdrops were grayish blue in
the soil so that's they've color
corrected the prints available now from
NASA where the soil is grayish blue to
match the projected backgrounds but at
the time you could see the fake
background a lot
easier 10 years after that at age 24 I'd
become a filmmaker whose job is to make
fake scenes look real and one day I'm
editing for a person who actually
produced the show I had seen 10 years
earlier and I'm like you remember that
guy on your show who said we didn't go
to the Moon I'd like to talk to him
because it was kind of bugging me if
they didn't fake you know or if they did
fake it and didn't really go that's
pretty significant he said I don't
remember the guys name but called the
San Francisco office I did they said had
I called one or two days later they
wouldn't have been able to tell me
because they deleted 10-year-old files
during the process of throwing them away
because you know videotapes take up a
lot of space and so I contacted him and
he said as a filmmaker I should make a
documentary about it so I looked into it
and started finding more and more clues
that indicated that it was fake in fact
you can prove that the moon missions are
fake with one single photograph so here
on the left is a segment from my film
this is a a picture I took out in
sunlight now the sun is about a million
times bigger than the earth it's about
93 million miles away so it's going to
cast shadows in the same direction over
the entire Earth or moon or front yard
or backyard so you'll see these two
telephone poles the Shadows are run
parallel it's impossible for them to
intersect out of the picture where the
shadow starts running up the side of the
house it still is parallel as both
Shadows run up the side of the house
they're still parallel and can't
intersect so the landscape curving is
irrelevant it's impossible for Shadows
to intersect in sunlight mathematically
Impossible on the
right correct on the right is a picture
they claim was taken on the moon from
the last mission where the astronaut
Shadow is at 12:00 and a rock about 5T
away is 9:00
so take it from a filmmaker this light
whatever is lighting this scene is a
really close meaning it's an electrical
light and seeing how there's no
atmosphere on the moon the sunlight is
about 20 times brighter than a desert on
Earth so you don't need any supplemental
lighting during the day on the moon so
the only way these Shadows could be
intersecting at 90 degrees from objects
5T apart as if it's an electrical light
you know very close to these objects to
where the difference from the light to
the Rock to the person throws off the
you know the shadow so we just proved an
accord of law with this picture that the
moon landings are fake because it means
it was taken with electrical light which
means they're on Earth which means they
didn't go to the moon and that's from
the you know alleged last mission but
basically uh I realized that there's
things that don't look right about this
I mean and to tell you Truth uh I was
scared because I have this kind of
Relentless personality to never give up
and I also like mazes I drew mazes as a
kid that adults couldn't do wow and so I
knew if I have this never give up
personality and I love puzzles if anyone
could figure out whether he went to the
moon or not it would be me and then I
thought if they faked it they're not
going to like people exposing that yeah
I would that would be dangerous they
might k me so I actually turned down the
project Mikey I said look I want to have
a wife and family Someday I'm not going
to risk my life for what Nixon did I
turned down the project wow then I had
another client a famous quote Christian
musician called Dino
konakis this kind of Christian Liberace
and uh his wife said they would get a
script of mine to this Hollywood
producer uh you know to to maybe make
into a feature film if I did them a
favor I'm like sure what favorite get
this they said read the Bible wow so so
they suggested I buy this oneye Bible
which I did and I started reading June
3rd 1988 the day the man stood in front
of the tanks in
China and June 3 of the following year I
had read the Bible one time and then and
I ended up reading the Bible at that
point five times from cover to cover
that is amazing I still wasn't a
Christian but it convinced me that the
Bible is true they don't make stuff up
if they did they would cover up the sins
of the man after God's Own Heart who
committed adultery and then murder to
cover it up right and when someone says
on the first year of the reign of King
so and so and the seventh month on the
13th day you know this happened it
probably happened right specific and
secular people who are atheist said if
Jesus of Nazareth was not the Messiah
there's no one who ever will be because
he did raise the dead he did give sight
to the blind they have so many witnesses
of that fact so I realized first of all
uh that there is a God even though I
wasn't a Christian and and it kind of
makes sense that there's a judgment for
how you live your life and then I
realized what was holding you
back holding me back from what from
becoming a Christian for me I had a
party lifestyle and I thought drug and
rock and roll okay there you go yeah I
think we're I think we're twins man back
when I was thin and I had hair oh you
know I lost this at 22 and uh you know I
had multiple girlfriends at a time I was
smoking pot drinking wine doing ecstasy
you know enjoying the world the worldly
life why would I you know give that up
at that point but it it did make sense
to me that uh there is a judgment for
how we live our life it said so multiple
times in the Bible that I had readed
five times from cover to cover and then
I realized you know I'm going to die
anyway and if they fake the moon
landing that is actually more profound
of an event historically than if they
had actually gone do you realize this
Mikey let's say they could somehow fly
to the moon and come back even though
today they can only go 1,000th as far
right oh that was a close one and so
that has a certain level of significance
historically
or they didn't go they falsified it they
embezzled $250 billion and they murdered
innocent people to cover it up if that's
true which it is yeah then that is so
much more profound than if they'd
actually gone do you see that one of the
greatest events in history isn't putting
a man on the moon it's the faking of the
moon mission by the most powerful Nation
on Earth and having podcasters who
anti-corruption anti-de State like Glenn
Beck defending the moonlanding wow he
says you know I know America has gotten
bad but at least we went to the moon so
as God would have it five years later I
changed my mind I called Bill caseing
back up and I said I changed my mind I'm
gonna die anyway this is worth dying for
if they fake the moonlanding and the
whole world is deceived especially
Americans This is significant because
until a bank robber is caught they just
keep robbing banks and if these people
and their Kindred Offspring in the
government remain in power we're doomed
and so we need to expose this and so I
called them up I said I changed my mind
and as God would have it I immediately
thereafter met a millionaire who builds
rockets for NASA who knew the
moonlandings are fake who gave me a
million dollars to produce a Funny Thing
Happened on the Way to the moon and
astronauts Gone Wild now as you just
showed from a Funny Thing Happened on
the Way to the Moon just go to the
homepage of cell.com that's SSN samam IB
ASM boyel
sell.com you can watch the rest of the
movie A Funny Thing Happened on the Way
to the Moon those are clips from my book
my book goes into so much more detail
that the film doesn't go into and has
177 interactive links that back up
everything that I am
saying so I start producing this film
when I had become a Christian that's why
it started with scripture and I show the
Tower of Babel Jesus
said if you start a tower and don't
finish you're proclaiming to the world
what a fool you are and so as you know
from Genesis 6 the Tower of Babel was
built just to show off to make a name
for ourselves and until about 250 years
ago for thousands of years the height of
human achievement was the height of the
tallest building they could build right
yeah and being an Adventist like I am
also me too Ellen White said Ellen White
said about the Tower of
Babel the monument to their pride became
a memorial of their Folly wow and it was
never finished you understand an
unfinished Tower then in the film again
you can watch it later on the homepage
of cell.com for free they built in the
technological age the century that
invented the TV the radio the computer
they built the largest machine ever
built the Titanic and they put in print
the ship that God himself could not sink
that was so stupid I think that woke up
from map didn't it yeah and uh then
Richard Nixon when he knew they were not
there nevertheless said putting a man on
the moon is second and great only to God
making the universe wow so not only from
a secular point of view is the most
powerful nation in the world apparently
the most corrupt we start wars halfway
around the world for reasons that are
completely fabricated and
they and yet when someone has a conflict
with someone on their border we somehow
say it's wrong for them to go to war but
we go Halfway Around the World endlessly
to start wars that we say are righteous
okay if that nation is the one who faked
the moon landing we're in deep trouble
and the world is in deep trouble and as
you know one of the Adventist teachings
is revelation 13 second beast you know I
had read that almost 10 times more than
that because I read the New Testament
about 25 times and I never realized
there's a separation the United States
is likely the second beast of Revelation
13 only can be that's right the boun
of the church that controls the world
and where do all the world leaders go to
and Kiss the Ring of a particular
religious leader right so I was
producing the film under the theory it
might be true that they faked it it took
seven years to produce the film 4,000
hours of editing and three and a half
years into this project I pop in a tape
that says on the screen do not show to
the public and I'm like oh this should
be good I figured if they faked it
they're more likely to have made a
mistake the first time they faked it so
I said I'm doing a documentary about the
moonlandings which is true shrewd as a
snake innocent as a dove I'm not gonna
say hey can you send me proof that it's
fake but send me everything from just
the first mission every picture every
still picture every video every film and
there's very few pictures there's less
than 20 pictures of an astronaut
standing on the surface of the Moon from
the first mission
and zero of Neil Armstrong there was
actually not a still picture of Neil
Armstrong on the Moon believe it or not
he didn't want his picture taken that is
interesting and in the process of this I
find a classified reel that a
whistleblower at Nasa apparently gave me
and they're faking part of the mission
over and over and over again right in
front of your eyes with a third track of
audio of the CIA telling him how to do
it and when I saw that I'm like Oh my
gosh they really did fake the moon
landing so the first proof is those
Shadows that intersect at 90 degrees
which is an impossible in sunlight which
means it's electrical light which means
it's on Earth which means they didn't go
to the Moon there you go I and the
second Pro yeah go ahead I want to um
make sure I got something straight so
you somebody told you like 10 years
after the moon landing that it was fake
that seed was planted then you were
going to make this documentary and
somebody else told you that the moon Lan
was fake you should make a documentary
about it the guy that you saw on TV and
then when you came back there so then
the the footage that you got was from
somebody else another whistleblower at
Nasa right correct basically you know I
grew up being Gaga kind of like the Saul
of the moonlanding not only believing
they were real worshiping them and then
just like Saul now going to being their
greatest critic and and when I was first
asked to do this movie I turned it down
because there was there was a lot of
evidence that indicated maybe they
really did fake it and if I start UNT
turning these rocks that would be
dangerous I'm not going to risk my life
for what Nixon did but you know but then
I after reading the Bible five times and
realizing it's there is a judgment there
is a God and if they faked it that's
more profound than if they had actually
gone which would be a hidden truth that
mankind must know in order to advance as
a culture and a species and a spiritual
being and as Government controlling men
lying to them embezzling their money to
deceive them and to hire people to kill
their brothers and sisters who are
trying to expose their crimes so wow
when I found this tape and we'll talk
about that and do a screen share and
show it I'm like oh my gosh I just was
on Candice Owens and I showed her the
tape she's like yeah oh it was amazing
and that's that was my reaction she
already knew they didn't go and here's
the second proof okay so the first proof
is Shadows intersecting at 90 degrees
from objects 5 feet apart we can show it
again if you want to or just go back and
look at it in sunlight go out in your
front yard look at two trees two
telephone poles two people standing on a
cloudless sunny day it's impossible for
their Shadows to intersect on the right
90 degree intersection 5 feet apart
electrical light that's really close
which means they didn't go there you go
you just proved it right there so that's
proof they they fake the moonlanding and
uh so the second proof is logic today
with 55 years better technology the
farthest that NASA can send an astronaut
into space is
1,000th the distance to the Moon so what
they're really claiming is that back in
19 69 before cell phones and microwave
ovens when all of Nas's computers
combined had one millionth the computing
power for cell phone they sent
astronauts ahead of schedule on the
first attempt a thousand times farther
into space than they can do today with
five decades better technology so
they're actually claiming that they had
a thousand times greater technology in
1969 than they do today which is a
historic and scientific impossibility
you cannot have greater technology in
the past and in the future when Lindberg
flew across the Atlantic in
1927 imagine if 50 years later nobody
can fly across the Atlantic and instead
of being able to fly 3,000 miles they
can only fly three miles in an airplane
no years later airplanes were so much
more advanced just 10 years after atomic
bomb you know was exploded for the first
time
atomic bombs were 1,000 times more
powerful if they could go to the moon on
the first attempt with one million to
computing power of a cell phone wow we
would have been on Mars 10 years later
we'd be in another you know solar system
by now and there'd be bases all over the
moon somehow we can drive cars and play
golf on the moon with one Milli the
computing power cell phone on the first
attempt and today with five decades
better technology the best they can do
is have mannequins orbit the Moon and
one of the clips that we'll show is
NASA's own engineer saying there's a
radiation field surrounding the earth
that you'd have to go through to the
moon no and that the technology to do it
and survive hasn't been invented yet oh
so there you go so that's the second
proof that we didn't go to the Moon
every Mann Mission Gemini Mercury skyb
the space shuttle has all been below the
radiation except going to the Moon you'd
have to go through it this is at least
30,000 miles thick so here's NASA's
engineer saying that the technology
necessary to do this has not been
invented yet okay so you just heard him
say we must solve these challenges
before we send people through this
region of space which means the
technology necessary to go through the
radiation belts has not been invented
yet so how did they go to the moon when
I called to talk to this guy they forbid
him to talk to reporters after he put
his foot in his mouth and when they sent
unmanned probes into the radiation belt
with two Geer counters to get the
readings I said give me those readings
they said it's a military secret wow and
I'm like well this is a CI a civilian
probe when you set probes to the Sun to
find out how much helium is in the sun's
atmosphere the amount of helium is in a
military secret or when you sent a probe
to find out how much hydrogen is in
Jupiter's atmosphere that amount isn't a
secret why would the amount radiation
surrounding the earth secret unless as
this guy just said it proved they didn't
go to the Moon because as he said we
must solve these challenges before we
send people through this region of space
so you can't even send onboard computers
and yet they're sending people in 1969
and we got a a little remote control car
on Mars but yet he's admitting we can't
even send a computer through that thing
okay so he basically said right now all
we can do is orbit the earth which is
just what the previous guy said and then
he says we hope to eventually go to the
moon now here's a clip that just came
out this this one uh that that I'm
showing here is a congressman about
three weeks ago saying we need to beat
China to the Moon Oh I thought we did
that
1969 right you know yeah so uh in any
case uh there's you know quite a bit of
evidence of NASA inadvertently saying
they cannot go to the Moon he says we
must solve these challenges before we
send people through this region of space
meaning they haven't solved the problem
yet so how can they send people through
that region of space to the Moon they
can't which means they didn't go to the
moon and that's why they had greater
technology in the past and in the future
for the first time in world history
because it was a bluff it was a fake
technology then we have a clip here if
you you know this is the you can go to
sa.com and listen to it but it's a hot
microphone left on in an astronaut's
house who I showed the fake footage to
and his son is threatening to call the
CIAA to have me
killed oh I have that one this is has to
do with we have an eyewitness who was
there at Canon air force base when they
filmed the fake moonlanding and he said
so as he was dying uh this is the Slate
that says do not show to the public this
is a report so this this is unedited fo
this is the beginning where they say uh
basically they're faking being halfway
to the Moon they claim this is the Earth
floating in space but this is actually a
circular window of the spacecraft with
the camera back away from the window
with all the lights turned off and
they're pretending that this is the
small Earth you know far away from the
Earth but they're still in Earth orbit
we when you go to shell.com and see this
and a Funny Thing Happened on the Way to
the moon on the home tap yeah this this
was like for me this was the nail in the
coffin I was already skeptical with the
shadows and stuff but when I saw this in
your documentary I was just like this is
Case Closed
man yeah here they are they're saying
it's playback and not live here is when
an astronaut's arm actually gets in
front of the
window so one of the astronauts actually
said that the camera was like flush
against the
window yeah he's line it would have to
be if this is really the Earth floating
in space then the camera would the lens
would have to be at the windows glass
but this is really a circular window of
the spacecraft they inserted a crescent
piece of material into the window to
make it look like the Terminator line
between night and day here he is falsely
claiming that he's halfway to the Moon
130,000 miles out and I'll put on the
right hand side of the screen sorry this
window and this is the unedited version
so on the left here is allegedly the
Earth floating in space right and then
here on the right is the unedited
version right because he said this was
the Earth floating in space and now on
the right hand side we have the unedited
version where you see it's a mockup of
the circular
window and the unedited reel where
they're breaking down the tape and this
is why they didn't want the public to
see it and you'll see Hands going in
front of the window and a minute there's
a work light on the left hand side there
and here they are breaking down the
effect so that's them inside the
spacecraft in front of the window that's
a one foot model of the Earth they're
pretending to be halfway to the moon the
lights come up the camera's been at the
back of the spacecraft the entire time
and that's the very bright and near
Earth out the window so that that's what
convinced me and everybody else that
they did in fact fake the moon landing
and uh that's you know pretty sad when
you realize that that's that's the
footage that convinced me that they
didn't go to the moon and two NBC News
directors have seen that and they both
agree it proves that they didn't go to
the Moon they're faking being halfway to
the Moon which means they can't go
halfway which means they didn't go and
that's why even 55 years later they
still cannot leave Earth orbit the
engineer just said so we must solve
these challenges of radiation before we
send people this through this region of
space which you'd have to before they go
to the Moon that's why the spa astronaut
says we hope to eventually go to the
Moon that's why the congressman says we
want to beat China to the
moon and now you everything's fallen
into place except this is a great
embarrassment to the United States
government so the First NBC news
director refused to broadcast it for
fear it would cause a civil war wow
second you know 10 years later they fly
me to New York they're going to break
the story Nationwide NBC News and they
get a call from the federal government
threatening them to unplug NBC or
something like that and they back down
so so this is a secular issue of fraud
in the federal government and it's a
spiritual issue because it's Mankind's
greatest accomplishment I remember Mikey
going to church on some Wednesday night
when it's interactive and someone said
you know who's the lord of the Earth and
everyone's like Jesus and the preacher
is wrong read your Bible Luke chapter 4
Satan says that he belong that all the
kingdoms of the world belong to him and
he can give them to whoever he wants
because Adam and Eve gave them their
Authority and that's why our world
leaders are Liars who's the father of
lies and how ironic in a fallen world
that Mankind's greatest
accomplishment is an unfinished Tower
you see that now if there's anyone in
the government who sincerely wants to
end corruption they have the number one
tool to do it which is to tell the
public that the moon landings were fake
then they will have both Republicans and
Democrats behind them and they'll say
see I told you how bad this was so the
moonlanding fraud has to come out for
the betterment of mankind both
spiritually and secular if the next
president whoever that is sweeps this
under the rug well they're complicit
with it they claim they want to in
corruption but the best way the key the
number one tool to get the public behind
ending corruption is to show them that
they were faking the moonlanding fraud
and then my book which is at sell.com
which is in audio that I read myself
Kinder or
print I discuss not only did they fake
the moonlanding but they murdered the
crew of Apollo 1 to cover it up the crew
that was going to be the first crew to
walk on the moon I interviewed the man's
Widow for 4 hours and son for three
hours they said he was murdered by the
CIA for not cooperating with fraud in
the aollo program and so not only did
they use our own money to deceive us
they used it to pay the salaries of CI
agents to kill honest astronauts who
wouldn't participate in the fraud that
that's coming out we founded our country
because King George had been an obstacle
to what life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness what's the first one life our
federal government is killing their own
people wow according Kennedy Jr who has
more access to the JFK files than Oliver
Stone does he's 100% certain that the
CIA killed President Kennedy because he
was GNA shut them Robert mcnamer defense
secretary as he was dying he said that
the entire start of the Vietnam War the
Pearl Harbor Event to get public support
was completely manufactured by him in
the CIA so the federal government is
willing to kill their own president
they're willing to start a war without
reason that kills 58,221
have an eyewitness and I'll show if you
want to share screen I'll show his
picture here this gentleman is cus acres
and he was the chief of security at
Canon air force base and he said was
dying that he wanted to confess that
he's a murderer Wow and his son who I
interviewed said well Dad who did you
kill he said well I was the chief of
security at the most secretive Air Force
Base Canon air force base and I killed a
coworker to cover up a secret so because
he was going to BL order the military
police came in to investigate to give
the victim's family closure because it
was like he just disappeared from work
one day and they said why did you kill
him and he said to cover up the
moonlanding fraud because the
moonlanding was filmed at Canon air
force base June 1st 2nd of 3rd of
1968 President Johnson
on vacation to eyewitness the filming of
Apollo 11 the first of three days of
filming so Johnson supervised it Nixon
gave it the thumbs up so both the
Republican and Democratic party are
against the people wow and there's he G
he kept the list if you want to take a
look at this here's the list of 15
people that President Johnson personally
gave this this gentleman in charge of
the security of the fake moonlanding
he said only these people are allowed in
Lyndon Johnson president Neil Armstrong
and Edwin Aldren who only I witnessed it
as doubles were in their space suit with
their visors closed wow W Von Brun the
the Nazi who was about to be thrown in
jail for war crimes Robert emmenegger
who was a science fiction writer who
spent his whole life saying UFOs are
real and the moonlandings are real so I
guess UFOs are is real as the
moonlanding Eugene CR flight director
James web Joseph ceran NASA astronaut
administrators James Van Allen was there
of the Van Allen radiation belt and
other CIA employees and so not only do
we have shadows intersecting at 90
degrees from objects 5 feet apart not
only do we have the logic you can't have
a thousand times greater space traveling
technology in 1969 than you do today not
only do we have that footage of them
faking being halfway to the Moon with
the one foot model of the Earth we have
an eyewitness who saw them Faking It who
confessed to a homicide to cover it up
so that's four times the proof that you
need to prove it in a court of law that
they did fake the moon landing and what
what representation of a fallen world is
a better example than that and people
are pridefully defending it they're
defending their own
molesters right it's pretty sad yeah
people don't want to admit that they
have been duped and I've admitted it
I've been duped by the media I've been
duped by NASA I've been duped by so many
things in life and my entire life I've
been a truth seeking so I've been three
things a truth seeker and an open-minded
skeptic those three things and that's
what's got me where I'm at today I was
raised in church as a little kid I
accepted Christ at nine years old but I
was obsessed with the Paranormal
checking out books on ghosts and aliens
and elementary school and when when the
church didn't have good answers for my
tough questions I went away and part of
it was the seduction of the media uh
rock and roll like you said MTV would
look so seductive to me and I didn't
want to dedicate my life to a
potentially a lie if I became a
Christian and miss out on all the quote
unquote fun in this life and so I
started asking tough questions and the
church dropped the ball and so I think
it's really important the truth will
make you free but I had to learn the
hard way I went down the road of
Witchcraft and all that from the age of
you know 14 to 21 when I actually hit
kind of a rock bottom and found out that
the Bible is real and all that and but
my search for truth never stops even now
I'm still a truth seeking open-minded
skeptic and it's caused me to question
even the beliefs of the Bible that I was
taught growing up and now I know you
know what the bible really teaches that
there's things that are I mean for
example Jesus warned you have let go of
the commands of God Y for the sake of
your tradition Trad all the other Ten
Commandments are valid do not kill do
not commit adultery so why would one in
the middle the Sabbath not be valid if
God never changes you see and so what is
Sunday they have let go of the commands
of God fourth Commandment for the sake
of their tradition which is Sunday right
that that's why I joined the Adventist
Church because they were correct about
the Sabbath I'd been deceived about that
and there's a foreshadowing of it in
Daniel 7:25 that the Antichrist will be
so arrogant as to change God's times and
laws and the Sabbath is one of them and
so if the truth sets us free amen then
lies make us enslaved right so as long
as Americans believe the lie of the
moonlanding they are enslaved Glenn Beck
is enslaved he's a Christian he's
anti-de State and he is enslaved because
he has on a man I forget the the
astronaut's name they parade him on they
have me on by Audio for 14 minutes and
they have him on for video for an hour
Charles Duke who has the audacity to
claim he's a Christian and lying about
walking on the moon which led to the
deaths of many of his colleagues and
Glenn Beck is taking his side he's
enslaved he's enslaved by the pride of
wanting America to at least not be so
bad as to have faked the moonlanding
Tucker Carlson when he heard that the
president's phone calls were being spied
on by the NSA he says that's absurd as
absurd as the moonlandings being fake oh
my God and then it comes out and then it
comes out the president's phone calls
are being spied upon you should have
known that years earlier when they did a
transcript of one of phone calls in the
New York Times where do you think they
got that from the CIA it's no it's no
mystery his phone calls are being spied
on and not just because it's him they
did that to everybody to Blackmail them
so if that ends up being absurd but true
as the moon landings and then here we
are 55 years later and the farthest they
can send an astronaut into outer space
is 1,000th the distance to the Moon and
the congressman says we need to beat
China to the moon and a shuttle
astronaut says we hope to eventually go
to the moon and their own engineer says
there's dangerous radiation and we must
solve that before we send people through
there to the Moon
they haven't solved the problem that's
why there's mannequins orbiting the moon
because they would die from the
radiation this is a positive lie that's
the problem that people have from not
seeing the truth you can change who shot
JFK and why but it's still a tragedy or
change who did 911 and why it's still a
tragedy this is a positive lie this is
giving people the pride-filled sweet
candy that they want when the reality is
a big play to manure and it says at you
know end of each chapter of my book
again at cell.com in audio Kindler or
print that I read myself each chapter
ends with a quote and one of the
chapters is uh from Men In Black 3 it
says the uh bitterest truth is better
than the sweetest lie oh and that's how
we have to perceive and really be a
trueth Seeker I think it was um a famous
writer said it is easier to fool people
than to convince them that they have
been fooled that's true and we have a
quote from Carl Sean who I just found
out knew the moon landings were fake but
didn't say so publicly he says once
people have been bamboozled long enough
they're no not interested in finding out
the truth the LIE has captured them
because they will not admit that they
have been deceived and he says once you
give a charlatan power over you you must
never get it back so whoever becomes
president they have to tell the truth
about the moonlanding fraud or they're
complicit to it and it will be the
number one tool to unite Americans
against the Deep State that's what the
news director tried to tell me all those
years ago and I didn't see it until now
it will enrage the public more people
died from 9911 more people died covering
up the Kennedy assassination than faking
the moonlanding but this is burned in
people's hearts they waved their Flags
they cried they prayed they printed it
on coins they printed it on lunch boxes
they put it in encyclopedia they gave
them Medals of Honor for being such good
liars yeah you see people are deceived I
even had a college professor say that if
he saw Neil Armstrong confess on
national TV that the moon missions were
fake he would still think they were real
anyway I cannot believe people have
literally made a God out of the
moonlanding and now we know it's a false
god
and wouldn't it be interesting if just
like the Tower of Babel Ellen White's
quote came true think about this about
the moonlanding fraud the monument to
their pride became the memorial to their
Folly wow that could happen if whoever
becomes president really loves America
they will tell the truth buz Aldren
endorsed Trump and said God Bless
America well God is not going to bless
America when they're founded on Lies
when they murder their own citizens and
murder their own presidents our country
is a thousand times more corrupt than
King George ever was they're taking away
life we have to ask permission to have a
birthday party on more than four people
in our house wow it's our house how can
you how you can you come and arrest us
for saying we have five people when the
limit is four during a birthday party
and they arrest the person and turn off
their
electricity what the Constitution says
they won't establish or prohibit a
religion and yet they closed churches
and then they open churches and said you
can go but you can't sing first they
said you can't have a wedding reception
then they said well now you can but you
can't dance well why is one group of
people telling another group of people
that they can't dance at their wedding
that's slavery how how can you not see
that and we are enslaved because we
don't know the truth and the greatest
truth about the greatest corruption is
the moonlanding fraud it's the number
one tool to Bringing Down the corruption
getting the American people United
behind that cause yeah I say the moon
landing and 911 are like Pandora's box
if you can't see those are fake and
inside job then you're never going to be
able to see some of the other false
flags and things like that like those
have the most evidence that proves that
they were faked or an inside job and
like you said that people are just
they're prideful they don't want to eat
crow basically and have to admit that
they idolized a
lie well they a lot of people don't
believe in God anymore therefore they're
Gods or politicians right the polit you
know' got our best interest in mind this
politician is bad and this politician is
good or they're both bad God says
there's no one who does right not even
one right so both are bad you see you
can't make Gods out of out of people you
vote for they they say before they're
elected I swear I will not mandate a
medicine for an illness you don't have
if you're a federal employee they become
president and they mandated did no one
forget they broke their word shouldn't
that be illegal for someone pledging
something and then not doing it once
they're elected that should be a crime
in of itself that should be their last
day in office and they should go to jail
for 20 years for making a promise
running for office that they didn't
fulfill and contradict it that should be
a crime why isn't it I'm so glad to hear
your mindset on that because ever since
high school I've been like it doesn't
matter who's President nothing ever
changes I people say I vote Republican
because I'm against abortion well
abortion has been legal the whole time
nothing ever goes away and I don't
believe that anybody's vote counts I
believe it's all set up and I believe
that Satan is the God of this world like
you said and there's a pendulum effect
my whole life it's been you know one
right-wing president one leftwing
president I had Bush senior Bill Clinton
Bush Jr
Obama uh Trump
up just ask just ask Ron Paul or Bernie
Sanders if they can get a fair Shake no
Bernie Sanders was getting twice as many
votes as Hillary Clinton but she got
twice as many delegates anyway and they
said we can do that because we're a
private club but then you're using
voting machines that the taxpayers paid
for for the primaries you're using
election officials that we pay their
salaries of so that that is illegal how
can that be legal right how can Ron Paul
be getting more votes than anybody else
and yet they give him 1% of media
attention to get people to abandon his
campaign you see President Johnson was
supervising the moonlanding fraud he's a
Democrat and Richard Nixon said what a
great idea and gave it a thumbs up so
both sides are against us right that
they want the most popular person to win
go ahead vote see if it matters right it
doesn't matter you think K Kennedy was
you know we he was duly elected and they
got rid of him because he was
anti-corruption I believe he was our
last president you know he exposed the
Freemasons in his last public speech and
yeah I think he knew too much they were
distracting him with maril Monroe and
all this stuff blackmail and yeah I I
think he had
a a conscious you know he was gonna
expose this stuff I wanted to go through
I'm not sure about that but huh but uh
you know you know I don't know the dead
guy's not here to uh defend himself
but a lot of people think he was not
faithful to his wife and maybe that's
why God let him be shot right you can't
have somebody claiming to be faithful to
people they've never met to citizenry
when they can't be faithful to the
mother of their children amen maybe God
allowed him to be killed because of his
infidelity and so we don't know what we
do know is we live in a fallen world
people don't believe in God anymore so
they don't see good versus evil what is
the number one story on the news all the
time radio or TV politics politics
politics well politics have been around
for thousands of years and more people
died of genocide in the last 100 years
in the entire history of mankind so it's
getting worse not better they're getting
so bad they're faking the moonlanding
killing their own people to cover it up
and they even have naive people
defending their own murderers and their
own deceivers right because it's a
glorious lie they want to hear Santa
Claus for adults so that's right if the
truth doesn't come out out there is no
hope for America there's no hope for the
world pray maybe the truth will come out
pray my first feature film uh may get
made we're trying to raise $7 million to
produce a film that's secular but with a
spiritual message in it
hopefully and uh pray that the truth
about the moonlanding fraud comes out
and we'll see what happens that'll be
awesome man I I wanted to show some
clips that you you talked about some of
these but just in case somebody in here
never heard of these these weren't
actually in your documentary because
this stuff came out later but this isn't
the case is only getting worse and worse
like your documentary exposed that it
was fake but now it's like they keep
shooting themselves in the foot over and
over and over these are actually part of
my book my book is interactive it's at
cell.com and you don't have to buy the
book to see the links but it has 177
interactive links and this is one of
them oh okay uh there's so much more
information in the book than in the
movie including the deathbed confession
of the eyewitness to the moonlanding
fraud but this is one of them where they
say they intentionally destroyed the
technology now if there was any
technology they might consider
intentionally destroying it would be the
atomic bomb okay right we used it to end
World War II but let's not let's not go
there again let's throw all that
technology in the furnace but only 10
years later atomic bombs were 1,000
times more powerful so again if we could
go to the Moon with one M the computing
power of a cell phone in
1969 we would have been on Mars 10 years
later and another solar system by now
and there'd be bases all over the moon
but there aren't any simply because it
can't be done and this astronaut says
not only and they only go 1,000th as far
55 years later that they intentionally
destroyed all the moonlanding technology
now if you spend an equivalent of $250
billion developing the moonlanding techn
techology that works so great why would
you throw all the hardware all the
blueprints all the schematics all the
original Telemetry all the original vide
tapes away you would never do that if
you really went but that's exactly what
you would do if you perpetrated a fraud
so the fact that they destroyed
everything is actually proof of the
fraud that's right here he is oops I
don't know what
I don't even know how you destroy a
technology it it doesn't make any sense
well they they just they did they
literally took all the original
videotapes and destroyed them they took
the they took the Telemetry data where
the rocket really was they destroyed
that they destroyed the machines that
could play it back that were oneof a
kind machines they destroyed the
schematics to blueprints because they
could prove later that it didn't have
the battery power to bring you know air
conditioning down to 72 degrees to
combat an outside temperature of 250
degrees on the moon for three days and
then Von Bron says in order to go to the
Moon it would take a minimum of three
rockets that would that would weigh
800,000 tons each well the Saturn 5 only
weighed 2,500 tons that's a difference
of
30,000 time 3 or 990,000 % different so
they because the Saturn 5 could not
leave Earth orbit that's why Elon Musk
says it's going to take eight fuel trips
minimum to go to the Moon a recent Ted
Talk says it may take 24 fuel trips
that's why the destroyed all the
schematics all the diagrams because you
could prove the rocket didn't have
enough fuel to leave orbit you could
prove the lunar module didn't have the
capability to combat the temperature and
then there's microm meteorites that Von
Bron said would kill you
every 24 hours without going into a cave
or a lead Shield which they never did
either right now so this is why they're
destroying everything yeah I I'm reading
the comments right now they're saying
that they're not hearing sound even from
my Clips which has never happened before
that's okay you can you can go back when
you do the edited version of this and
insert all insert all these things with
audio I've got to run but uh you know
that's the Bas proof that you have that
we didn't go to the Moon four times more
than is necessary to prove it in a court
of law if it weren't for it being sweet
candy you know pleasurable lie as I say
Santa Claus for adults people would
accept it and if a college professor is
so Gaga made a God out of the
moonlanding he teaches Aerospace he said
Neil Armstrong confessing to it being
fake wouldn't dissuade him he'd think he
still walked in the moon anyway so as
you know from ignorant
that's right Obadiah says Pride blinds
you from seeing the truth and the most
important scripture to me is what good
is it to gain the whole world and
forfeit your soul and people who do all
of these things 911 kill Kennedy fake
the moon landing whatever they're doing
they're gaining the world and losing
their soul so all that we have to do is
get converted be faithful to the end and
God's grace will cover us into heaven it
looks like according to the scriptures
most people people aren't going to make
it Jesus says he was not sent to the
Gentiles or the pagans to the lost sheep
of Israel so everything he said is to
the church
including wide as the gate broad as the
road that leads to destruction he's
talking to the church most church people
are not going to make it he said there
will be such an increase of wickedness
where evil is called good that most
people will fall away Matthew 24 Only He
Who holds to the end will be saved
Hebrews 26 10:26 says if we deliberately
go on sinning we our Grace is Gone no
more sacrifice treating God
disrespectfully so there's two keys to
open a safety deposit box one is from
God he died for the whole world but the
other is repentance if we repent without
God's grace it's not going to open the
doorway to heaven but he opened it for
everyone but only a few repent because
it says I just read John 15 if you love
me keep my Commandments amen that's how
you prove you love God by giving up the
world so go to cell.com to get the book
see the Links come to the same sad
conclusion that I had to that the moon
landings were indeed
falsified and uh you can get it in audio
Kindle or print some people get it in
print and listen to the audio and it's
interactive I write a chapter and say
look if you want to understand a funny
thing happened you know go watch the
movie we're about to talk about the
second filmm astronauts gone wild go
watch that first so when I refer to it
you know what I'm talking about it and
let's just scroll through these these
links real fast when you got them on
there uh the the third one is
mindblowing the third one uh is just
boggles the mind there basically this is
a
1968 national anthem sign off that as
the lyrics change on the bottom you know
say can you see gly light
you see a subliminal message Crystal
Clear when you slow it down obey God uh
government is your god consume
government is God don't Rebel things
like that link four is the uh well this
too long to go into but you get the book
and you can see greetings friends and
countrymen welcome to
conspiracy I hear that one uh then
there's you know a better dissecting of
the proof there's you know you know all
these clips that show that sadly they
really did fake the moonlanding there's
the one that we just shown there's one
about Van Allen saying originally it's
the radiation belts are 100 times the
lethal dose mindboggling huh wow and so
what can you do they did fake the moon
landing and unless the truth comes out
America is sunk and the world is sunk so
pray that it comes out please pray for
my film silence in heaven we're trying
to raise $7 million Ron Pearlman uh is
says he wants to star in it and produce
it he says it's one of the best screen
plays he's ever read uh and it was
originally going to start Ed Asner until
he died uh so pray we raise the $7
million to do that film and of a
spiritual message about a person trying
to get right with God before they die
and uh hopefully we'll make the movie
and pray that the truth comes out to
give us a little bit of a rebuke that we
need that we did fake the moon landing
that is how low we have sunk and you can
watch all of this at
sell.com amen well I'm looking forward
to that movie I think that's a great
plan what you're talking about making a
secular movie because there's a lot of
people that they don't want to step foot
in a church they've already been hurt by
the church they think the church is
liars and hypocrites they don't want to
watch a Christian movie because it's
always cheesy or making atheists look
dumb I think it's amazing what you want
to do to put a a moral and even a gospel
message in a secular movie and so I'll
definitely be praying for that putting
that on the prayer list it's called
silence in heaven you
said that's right silence in heaven well
Bart thank you so much man this has been
amazing thank you for your time and I
pray that the stuff that you're putting
out opens eyes because the truth will
set you free and God's chosen you
clearly to be the man to get this
message out and so thank you for
bringing the truth you have on this
platform I really appreciate it sure
thanks for being my brother let's pray
we're both faithful to the very end amen
we'll see you then
bro all right God bless you have a good
night God bless his documentary was so
inspiring to me when I saw it like in
2012 and you know Satan doesn't want his
deceptions to be exposed and it's even
come against this live stream to where
you know done nothing different I'm
showing Keynotes the way I always show
them the way we do every time we do a
show and for some reason there's no
audio but I have more I would love to
show if I could get the audio going I
would love to just continue and show
some more uh evidence here what is that
in the top
left if that's the Earth is that like a
another spacecraft no no no
no that I have no idea what that is it's
I love his boldness man some aberration
on the film of some sort those
Shadows or Reflections probably
Reflections that are just reflecting
that back again so I get another shot of
it the light just filled the
spacecraft if you're going to press me
on this I'm not going to talk to you
anymore because I won't pursue this all
of this attempt to say the Apollo
programs were fake is just sheer
nonsense and you can talk till Hell
Freezes Over and you're wrong you can
talk till Hell Freezes Over and you're
wrong bar saell the dude we just had on
he went up to each of the astronauts and
showed them their own footage of them
faking being halfway to the moon so if
you guys are confused about that whole
window scene one of the astronauts was
explaining that they had the the camera
was flush against the window so if this
is the window the camera's against it
they're saying
that all everything you're seeing out
the window is Blackness of space and a
small little Earth because we're halfway
to the moon but what was just proven
when the light came in and you see the
astronaut was that the camera instead of
being flush against the window was way
back way back to the back of the of the
spaceship looking at lower Earth orbit
meaning the window was filled with
you know like looking out the window
from a plane like you're seeing all the
ground and the Earth and everything and
they cropped in the window to make it
look small and then that thing fell and
light filled up the Space Capsule I mean
this is this is crazy this is nail in
the coffin they faked going to the Moon
they faked halfway to the Moon you
wouldn't have to fake going halfway to
the Moon if you could go it's crazy so
here's Bart saell back when he had hair
he was younger and this is the guy that
he just showed this to watch his
reaction lying about going to the Moon
is a satanic of gigantic I don't hit
people but you're going to be on the
deck unless you get app and get the hell
out of my house
what get to get gun and shoot them at
them before they get out of the offet we
have a video camera running if you want
to do it right that would be great
footage for us
[Applause]
see you later in court I
hope you want to call the CIA have
whacked so okay if you really were an
astronaut that went to the moon and this
guy is showing you some footage wouldn't
it just be easy to explain it like no
this isn't fakery let me tell you what's
going on instead he gets enraged like
this was a normal interview he was
answering all the questions until this
footage triggered him why wouldn't he
just say no no that's not what you're
thinking it's this this and this he
knees him in the butt says get out of my
house and the guy that's with him says
you want me to call the CIA and have him
whacked like this was we want to kill
you because you showed this
footage that's that's damning evidence
right there that there is something to
hide that they he didn't say this he
could have said this is not actually
footage from us this is some faked stuff
or he could have just explained what
happened but instead he shot himself in
the foot and was caught
red-handed
insane so let me full screen this U this
is footage official footage from a Air
Force Base and you see it's coming from
this website that or this uh YouTube
channel that has 3.36 million
subscribers this is not a conspiracy
theory website this is
British path they are just a historical
news they're just like a historical
collection of footage they have no
agenda no conspiracy theory going on
here but check this footage out the
footage doesn't have sound so it's okay
that you guys don't hear it but they're
inflating this
balloon um I wish I knew more about the
clip are they're getting inside this
Capsule that's attached to the
balloon and this is supposed to be like
one of the first footages of space or of
stars in space and so here they are
wearing their astronaut
suits and everybody's recording and this
thing is floating
up everybody's watching oh man it's
going to take a while to get up there
ain't
it and there's the glory look at the
stars
are you kidding me there's a star
literally in the middle of the Moon look
at this are you kidding me like this
looks like a Laurel and Hardy movie or
something do you see that star do you
know why that is impossible because the
moon isn't a crescent it's a whole Moon
that's just like shadowed you shouldn't
be able to see a star in the shadow of
the moon or the stars in front of the
moon this is ridiculous like people
actually believe that this is
real but what's awesome is how many
people are waking up you look at the
comments here and people are like ah yes
a star shining through the moon LOL are
there still people that see the end of
this video and believe that uh what they
are seeing is actually really stars from
space all the Laughing faces state of
those quote unquote Stars never stops
NASA CGI has improved a lot since then
uh I can make better tiny holes into a
paper while sleeping this is crazy like
this is the stuff that people believe I
mean this is the stuff that's been put
out over the years that we went to space
it's insane so listen to this about
stars when you looked up at the sky
Could you actually see the stars and the
solar Corona in spite of the glare
we were never able to see stars from the
lunar surface or on the daylight Side of
the Moon by eye without looking through
the Optics uh I don't recall during the
period of time that we were
photographing the sonaa what what stars
we could
see I don't remember seeing
any dude okay so we just saw stars from
a balloon but they were in space they
were on the moon and like I don't
remember seeing stars ever the whole
time he said we couldn't see stars
unless we were looking through the
Optics I want you to notice the reaction
though okay so he just said his little
thing like we couldn't see stars unless
we're looking through the Optics or
whatever but watch when this guy starts
to talk watch his reaction he's
literally like whoa shut up dude watch I
don't remember saying anything he's like
dude come on man stop it's
enough do you see that I'm not not just
tripping here he's like
dude he gives him a look and then he's
like like like shrinking back in a
seat saying
any like come on man he's like okay so
you can see stars from a balloon but you
can't see stars when you're on the moon
I couldn't find the footage because you
would not believe how much this topic is
censored on YouTube whether it's the
shape of the Earth or
or uh you know the moonlandings are fake
all that stuff is so hard to find but
there was a time when the ISS was doing
a live feed supposedly live feed with a
school and somebody said are are you
able to see stars in the ISS and the guy
was like oh yeah you can see stars and
planets and and they're just but I think
it was that Don Pettis guy actually it
was him and somebody else and they were
just like oh yeah you can see all kinds
of stuff out here stars and planets but
these are the astronauts that went to
the moon and they don't even look happy
at this press conference they're like
all right if I went to the moon I would
not look so depressed like dude we just
people win the football game and they
are so they're screaming in the locker
room pouring uh Gatorade on each other
and these guys went to the moon and look
at their faces that should be damning
enough right there also right here it
says how NASA makes the those incredible
highres images of Earth this is from
wired this is not a conspiracy theory
website at all it's a technology website
and they're saying that that they get
their footage or they get the images
from a lowf flying satellite a low orbit
satellite that takes ribbons of images
and that's why you see these gaps you
see these little gaps here and they have
to fill those gaps in why if they have
satellites why don't they just go back
and take a whole picture of Earth for
one but instead it's literally like an
airplane flying over different parts of
the world taking ribbons of images that
have to be stitched together to on this
globe they have to put these pieces
together which means there's like empty
spaces between the ribbons that have to
be photoshopped in these are the
different
layers all these layers are put together
to make that picture of the Blue Marble
world that you all see on your
iPhones check it out then in 2002 Blue
Marble 2.0 NASA's Rob Simmon made this
Simmon's job is it's primarily taking
data and making pictures out of it
that's what this is a composite of data
sets from several different instruments
translated into a picture the to us the
really cool thing was the data set up
until that point there was no
realistic color map of the globe
anywhere so the land layer here comes
from the moderate resolution imaging
spectr radiometer aboard Tera and the
tricky part here was the weather so we
actually had to take clouds out they
stashed the clouds for later went onto
the ocean that came from an instrument
that measures phytoplankton in the sea
where it was low I colored it dark blue
because they're low mostly in mid oceans
and then where it was a little bit
higher it was like a little bit brighter
green then add the clouds back in
there's a small problem with it because
there's a very slight Gap in between
each orbit so some of those are painted
on it is photoshopped but it's it's has
to be it is photoshopped but it's it's
has to be it is photoshopped but it's it
has to be this is the guy who made the
Blue Marble that's on your iPhone he
admits it is photoshopped we had to fill
in the gaps because we don't have
technology to go back far enough and
take a picture of Earth and yet people
look at this on their phone and they
will show you that and say look the
Earth is a globe here's the proof we got
a picture of it like this is what BART
was talking about willful ignorance
believing in Santa Claus believing the
pride or or being so full of Pride that
you can't accept the truth that this is
not even a real picture he said we took
the clouds off and we put them back in
later that picture of the earth that was
in the fake footage of halfway to the
moon was placed
later in a picture of an astronaut on
the moon so look this was the
footage it says that same fake Earth
found its way into the moon so this is
the footage that Bart found that he got
given of them faking halfway to the Moon
look at the pattern on earth that is
that's cloud coverage there's no way in
all the Earth's history that that cloud
formation could be the same if the Earth
is turning clouds are a vapor that are
just being formed all the time but yet
when you zoom in on this picture of an
astronaut on the moon and look at the
foot look at the image of Earth it's the
same you see that right you see this
blue it's the same cloud formation it's
the same Terminator line everything
about this is the same which is why when
you put it inside of a
when you put it inside Photoshop and
start tweaking with the adjustment
layers you actually see that it's a
square same with the Earth if you take
these
original images and you put them in
Photoshop we now have the technology the
people have the technology to put these
things in a program and find out that
they're faked there's no way that that
happens in a photograph that a square
gets put around the Earth if you're
taking a photograph of Earth from the
Moon that's 100% proof me as a graphic
designer I know all about this I use
Photoshop constantly if you have the
magic wand tool and you make sure that
the the tolerance level is all the way
down it's only going to select that
exact color if that's any different
shade if that hexi code is even one
digit off it's going to show you and
reveal it and so this is another proof
that we never went to the moon that
these pictures are fake I think this is
so interesting this is straight off of
NASA I took this screenshot just to
prove that this is from NASA's website
it says from A Million Miles Away NASA's
camera shows Moon crossing face of Earth
now look at this I just want you to see
this this is footage of the moon this is
the Dark Side of the Moon that we're
seeing this is from I guess a satellite
that's higher than the moon
and it actually caught footage of the
moon going across the earth the earth is
fully lit which means the sun is behind
the moon and behind the camera
here and so that's why the Dark Side of
the Moon is fully illuminated because
the sun is hitting the the the moon
right
now what I want you to notice
is the clouds they are not
moving one inch the cloud CLS do not
move at
all in this video of the rotation of the
earth you know how fast clouds move it
said that this was a a picture taken
every 30 seconds for 10 frames that's
five
minutes in five minutes not a single
cloud changed position
formation come on man this is straight
from NASA be honest with yourself this
is not real I'm I'm looking at different
things that make me know this isn't real
there's some weird like Lighting on the
edge of Earth here uh this is a perfect
circle Neil degros Tyson says that Earth
is
pearshaped come on man like this is not
adding up there's no consistency with
space the globe
NASA uh these
physicist this is not a pear-shaped
Earth this is a exact perfectly round
like Photoshop circular Earth and the
moon the the clouds don't change
formation at
all and if you guys couldn't hear the
sound before we're going to listen to
Don Pettis say that he'd go to the moon
in a nanc except they destroy that
technology I'd go to the moon in a
nanc the problem is we don't have the
technology to do that anymore we used to
but we uh destroyed that technology and
it's a painful process to build it back
again it's a painful process dude we
have computers in our pocket we we are
all walking around with computers in our
pocket that can stream video to
thousands of people and back then in
1969 there may have been an Atari like
the computer level back then compared to
now and you're saying
that if you just look at the moon
lander that thing looks like it was made
by kindergarteners literally it looked
like a an a science project put together
with shower curtain rods and and gold
foil and a shed there's like a storage
shed on
top and it seemed like there was like
three different versions
of of how they went to space they got in
a rocket that thing flies up it turns
into the lunar module the thing with
legs and feet that don't have any dust
on them when they
land and then somehow when they got in
there that thing was able to take off
and go back to
Earth and land as some kind of capsule
from a
parachute dude there's nothing about
this that I'm buying and and here's
these guys saying that they can't go
they can't go higher than lower Earth
orbit right now we only can fly in Earth
orbit that's the farthest that we can go
and this new system that we're building
is going to allow us to go beyond and
hopefully take humans into the solar
system to explore so the Moon Mars
asteroids there's a lot of destinations
that we could go to and we're building
these building block components in order
to allow us to do that
eventually so he just said we can only
go to lower Earth orbit but maybe one
day we could go to places like the moon
and
Mars you mean like we did 1969 this is
crazy and then here's where he's saying
we need we need to build shielding on
Orion which is this other Space Capsule
thing there's not enough shielding to
get through the Van Allen radiation
belts but they had they would have had
to have gone through the Van Allen
radiation belts to go to the moon in
1969 and now we're talking about we need
to build shielding that can get humans
and computers onboard computers through
that radiation check this
out my name is Kelly Smith and I work on
navigation and guidance for Orion Orion
is is next Generation spacecraft built
with versatility in mind it can take
astronauts deeper into space than we've
ever gone before to an asteroid or even
onto Mars for these missions our rine
has to be one tough spacecraft with
standing high speeds searing
temperatures and extreme
radiation before we can send astronauts
into space on Orion we have to test all
of its systems and there's only one way
to know if we got it right fly it in
space as we get further away from Earth
we'll pass through the Van Allen belts
an area of dangerous
radiation radiation like this could harm
the guidance systems onboard computers
or other electronics on Orion naturally
we have to pass through this danger zone
twice once up and once back we must
solve these challenges before we send
people through this region of space for
this flight it's time to head home he's
literally telling you we can't go
through the Van Allen radiation belts
whether you believe in B and radiation
belts or not I don't anymore I used to
when I first heard about this stuff but
now I believe that there's a firmament
either way you can't go to space and so
I think the Van Allen radiation belts is
kind of the deception to say to prove or
to to explain why we can't go to space
or why we can't go to the moon but he's
literally saying like this was years
years after we went to the moon and he's
saying we are still working on shielding
to be able to get through that those
radiation belts not just for humans but
for even onboard computers so answer me
this how do we have a a little remote
control car on Mars right now that's a
onboard computer and how are we
controlling it from Earth I can't even
get a signal on my phone when I go into
the mountains or on an airplane but we
can control a remote control car are
from Earth come on guys we've been duped
so here's a a question asked to one of
the astronauts by Bart saell the guy we
just had on he was man he is such a tool
for God right now being able to
interview these astronauts being able to
get funded to make these documentaries
to be on platforms like Joe Rogan and
Candace Owens like the message is
getting out people are going to start
waking up like the Bible says there's
nothing covered that will not be
revealed in the last days but listen to
how their stories never line up any ill
effects from the Van Allen radiation
belts no now I'm not sure we went far
enough out to to encounter the Van Allen
radiation belt maybe we did beginning at
an altitude of 1,000 miles and extending
an additional 25,000 Mi lay lethal bands
of radiation called the Van Allen
radiation
belts every space mission in history
with humans on board from both the
United States and Soviet Union from the
first in 1961 to the present has been
well below this deadly radiation field
Mercury Gemini soy Skylab the space
shuttle all maintained altitudes well
below 1,000 miles all except
Apollo I don't know the distance to the
Van Allen radiation belt and if we did
it wasn't a problem the belts are 1,000
Mi to 25,000 Mi above the Earth we then
we went right out through them no
effects on yourselves didn't even know
it I don't think anybody well maybe
somebody said you went through the
radiation belt but we didn't feel it
inside are you an astronaut bro or are
you an astronaut this is I mean imagine
if I
said hey I've been to Six Flags and
you're like did you ride the roller
coaster I I I don't know if there was a
roller
coaster you'd be like are you kidding me
there's more than one there's the ninja
there's the Batman there's incredible
like are you kidding you went to the
moon and you don't you had to go through
months of training and going through all
these different things and you don't
even know where the vanal and radiation
belt are like you weren't primed for
that and prepped like hey now when you
get this far up you might feel a little
uncomfortable because there's severe
hands of radiation that you're going to
be going through and he's like no we we
must have went right through it I I
didn't even know about it this is crazy
guys when two astronauts were
asked is the the engine is it loud this
is what they said two conflicting
stories is the engine loud as you're
descending well the engine is very loud
it's very difficult to tell the
difference between feeling sound and
hearing sound but yes it's loud when you
were in it you couldn't hear it in the
vacuum of space
what do you think about that if you ask
two people hey you both were at that
party last night was the music loud and
one person was like oh yeah it was very
loud the other person was like I don't
know I couldn't hear
it you would be like what what's going
on were you guys really both at that
party or
not you got two people there was only
like three or four people right right
three people there's only three people
on the thing you're asking the same
question was it loud one says yeah it
was very loud and the other's like uh
you couldn't hear it no you couldn't
hear it in the vacuum of
space I mean this is this is damning
evidence these are
liars these people are
lying now when Buzz Aldren was asked why
haven't we been to the Moon in such a
long time he has a very interesting
answer check this out why has nobody
been to the Moon in such a long time
that's
not an 8-year-old's
question that's my question I want to
know but I think I
know cuz we didn't go there
and and that's the way it happened and
and if it didn't happen it's nice to
know why it didn't happen so
okay uh that's just the craziest answer
ever she said why has it been such a
long time he's like that's my question
well it because we didn't and if we
didn't then there's no like people can
say context whatever go look it up it's
like a 17 minute long video This Girl's
dad I'm sure um asked her to ask him
these questions and that's why he gives
like a nervous laugh when he goes oh
that's not an eight-year-old question
the dad's like but then he's saying
that's my question go watch it there's
no context that will make what he said
made make sense if he literally went to
the moon no context can explain what he
just said because we we didn't and
that's what happened I'll play it
again why has nobody been to the Moon in
such a long time cuz we didn't cuz we
didn't cuz we didn't go there
and and that's way it happened and and
if it didn't happen it's nice to know
why it didn't happen so it's nice to
know why it didn't happen it would be
nice to know why it didn't happen I want
to know now check this out this is crazy
so George Bush is being pushed through
the Space Center and there's footage
live quote unquote live footage from the
ISS going on in the background what do
you see that's interesting in the
background I see a a blue screen with a
grid on
it now that could just be normal I guess
I mean if you have you ever seen that in
the background of the ISS I don't know
um but that same guy the same guy
that's right here in the background you
you notice there's like his hand is up
he's playing with something that same
guy is right here showing you how you
can play with a bubble of water in space
now why is the background blue with a
grid on it and he's got a green ball
this is special effects happening right
it got caught right there on television
while they're pushing George Bush
through that Space Center this is the
technology that you're seeing this blue
grid is how they do live compositing
live keying because the camera and the
and the software can pick up on that
grid and even if the camera moves the
background moves with it so that you
look like you're in the environment and
this is live
keying this is exactly what they're
doing the ISS has been there's been so
many things that have shown that the ISS
is Faking it whether it's harness wires
or green screen glitches or bubbles in
space or hairsprayed hair instead of it
flowing around and we're going to look
at some of that stuff
what's up guys thank you for joining us
at truth to the youth I'm going to show
you these clips that I put together and
uh want you just be honest with yourself
while you're watching these clips um you
see this guy doing a back flip and
people are grabbing wires behind him
grabbing his wire on his leg this guy he
actually
falls halfway through his
flip um this guy he he tries to bend
down and can only go so far this guy
can't even do a back flip and zero
g and this lady grabs a wire as she
stands up now I'm going to show you all
these compar him side by side look this
guy's definitely struggling with a
harness wire on the left this guy on the
right's grabbing a cord that you can see
attached to his pants and the guy in the
background is swatting at a a wire he's
trying to
grab here the guy on the left Falls
halfway through his flip and on the
right this guy is lunging to do a back
flip and if this was zero g he would
just continue to go on but he
doesn't um here on the left we see this
lady grab a wire as she stands up or
she's just grabbing nothing maybe I
don't know on the right this guy bends
down but is stopped by resistance and
you see his shirt lift up in the
back so I mean you just have to be
honest with yourself is this zero g is
this really the ISS going on uh these
are scenes from the movie called life
it's about the ISS and you can see how
they're floating around with harnesses I
think this is how they're doing
it uh this lady's hair is just stiff as
a board standing straight up and that's
her proof that they're on the
ISS this lady's hair is bouncing right
back in place as she bends down I've
reversed it back and forth so you can
see how she moves her head forward and
instead of her hair freely flowing
forward bounces back in place same with
this Medusa chick here um she's
definitely in a zero g plane because
she's floating around but her hair is
hairsprayed stiff now if you were just
going to keep your hair out of your way
I would pull it back in a
ponytail but uh she's got a stiff now
this is what your hair would do in zero
g freely move not stiff as a board like
we see on the right here this is
hairspray this looks exact exactly like
what we see on the
ISS now sometimes we do see hair moving
freely on the ISS when it's a uh an
edited shot you know just little Clips
but if there's any long periods of shots
or live they definitely do the hairspray
so you can't tell when the plane levels
out but look at this hair freely
flowing on the ISS so both of these are
from the ISS but their hair is is doing
completely different things
so uh you come up with your own
conclusion
here but this is how I expect people to
fly around on the ISS just cork screwing
and going all crazy but they always just
do this back flip or this front flip
this stiff flip and then gravity hits
boom
wh there's that gravity all right thanks
guys uh just be honest with
yourself uh you know question everything
be a critical thinker and be honest with
yourself truth to the
youth so before there was candid truth
there was truth to the youth that video
is an older video I'll put the link in
the description so you can share it with
other people but there's no consistency
it that doesn't work in a story if the
story doesn't have consistency you know
they're lying it's all the more if it's
in video like we have women's hair
freely flowing in the ISS and women's
hair going straight up as if they're in
anti-gravity or hanging upside down or
just hairsprayed there's no free flow in
there and I don't know I don't
understand why people will choose to
believe this lie when they can see it
right there in side by-side comparisons
that there's zero consistency This Is A
Lie they are caught red-handed there's
evidence proof video proof that they're
lying that this
is video effects and in that movie uh
called life where they had people flying
around in the in the ISS they had
harness wires and it was easily removed
if Hollywood can do it with their budget
then NASA can do it with their budget
it's so simple like this this technology
is not difficult people act like there's
no way you can fake this stuff and it's
very simple if you've ever watched a
movie even as far back as uh Space
Odyssey 2001 A Space Odyssey that was a
year before the moon landing happened
and they were floating around in space
imagine what we can do now with the
technology we have now this is so easily
faked this is one of the first footages
of a space walk where he comes out of
the
spaceship okay I'm St right from the
spacecraft okay
I want you to pay attention to something
might
out I think I'm
ding I want you to notice
something okay I'm
out
[Music]
out that Earth doesn't look like it's
moving 1,000 mil hour I'll tell you
that now watch his head watch his head
okay put a little roll in it right out
pay attention to his head he's about to
turn to the camera and wave his head
just turned to the camera know I did you
see
that this looks like clay like this
seriously looks like gum you guys ever
saw flame Mason from the 80s but I want
you to pay attention to this watch that
head
[Music]
turn
yourbo
yourbo turn
ASA let's check it out does an
astronaut's helmet turn no an
astronaut's helmet does not turn that's
the official AI answer when you asked
Google I just looked this up before I
went live um AI is scouring the internet
and getting the best answer for your
question does an astronaut's helmet turn
no but we just saw it happen well maybe
we can't trust ai's answer let's let's
look further hey it's nor from tes.com
and I'm here at the neutral buoyancy lab
NASA's neutral buoyancy lab in Houston
Texas this is where NASA trains
astronauts before they can go to space
I'm here with Terry Dunn you're the
training operations manager and Terry
we're in front of a space suit right
this is the extravehicular mobility unit
or emu as we call it and it's the space
suit that astronauts wear for space
walks either the space shuttle back in
those days or the space station now and
so this has been used this is design
that's been used for decades right it's
essentially unchanged for the past 40
years okay he said it was used for space
walks he said it was unchanged for
decades listen what he says design
that's been used for decades right it's
essentially unchanged for the past 40
years okay so we just saw helmets don't
move from Google now we're seeing that
this the this right here this astronaut
space suit is the same model that has
been used for decades nothing's changed
listen and this is a very rigid suit
like there's not a lot of mobility in
here right the upper part that they call
the heart upper Toro for a reason it's
um really a hard shell and despite the
obvious Comfort level of that there's a
reason for it and you've got to have all
these different things the life support
system the controls for the suit your
tools all have to be rigidly mounted so
you need that hard shell to be able to
do that
you need that hard shell that rigidness
at the top okay we we're getting a
little bit closer but here is the nail
in the coffin and with the helmet on the
helmet doesn't turn when the astronaut's
head turns that's right your field of
view is very limited the helmet doesn't
turn when the astronaut's head turns
that's right your field of view is very
limited so is your situational awareness
and so you can basically look almost all
the way to your right and left and then
you need to be able to look down as well
correct so if you need to see beyond
those views you you're turning your
whole torso like you're in traction
you're turning your whole torso he's
saying the helmet doesn't move and this
is newer this is like a newer model he
could have said yeah back in the day you
know we didn't have the technology to
make your head move but now we do no
he's saying this model the helmet
doesn't move and it's the same unchanged
model that we've used for decades on
Space walks we're building the whole
evidence the whole evidence is what we
saw was footage of a space walk we saw a
helmet turn it looked like claymation
the Earth that wasn't spinning 1,000
miles an hour they're saying this is the
unchanged astronaut suit and it doesn't
turn the helmet does not turn you have
to turn your whole body come on are we
going to lie to
ourselves are we going to continue to
believe this fairy tale just because
what we think it's fun or we don't want
to believe that we've been lied to why
are we still believing this so how much
did the original moon buggy cost I just
think this is interesting the original
moon buggy cost also known as the lunar
roving vehicle had an initial contract
cost of1 million $19 million for that
thing but due to cost overruns the final
price reached $38
million $38 million you want to see what
that looks like
that's $38 million guys that seriously
looks like two lawn chairs on a on a
door with wheels attached to it how can
that cost $38
million
$38 million guys and that was back in
1969 come on dude 1969 $38 million for a
doom buggy and not even a really nice
one this is insane guys so the
astronauts got back inside the the moon
lander and they're going back home to
Earth who is recording
this they left the cameraman they left a
cameraman on the moon just for this shot
and it's not just a it's not like okay
they left a camera big deal we left a
cam cameras are very expensive it had
the footage in it how do we get how do
we even get this footage how are they
live streaming and
1969 dude I'm starting to like just dude
there's nothing about this that makes
sense how was
astronauts live streaming in
1969 when every phone had a cord
attached to the wall there was nothing
Wireless oh my goodness dude how did how
did anybody believe this look at
this the camera pans up it's not just a
camera left on a tripod
and like I was saying the footage would
have had the the camera would have had
the footage in it unless they're somehow
live streaming and I guess they did I
guess somehow they at least had a public
fooled that you could live stream from
the moon in 1969 with VHS
camcorders and they left someone on the
moon to record the the flight back home
oh my goodness guys oh we're so gullible
sometimes
and I wanted to to give a shout out to
Mark saell he's he's actually got a kids
book you guys have helped fund ABY
strange dreams book and I think it's
awesome that kids are going to get to
know about spiritual warfare how to
discern Spirits what aliens really are
and Bart saell has his own book a kids
book about the the great Earth hoax
about the moonlanding hoax I haven't
gotten a chance to read it yet but I'm
definitely going to get a hold of one of
these I was hoping to be able to this
shout out while he was still on but um
I'm going to go ahead and give it a
shout out now I hope this was eye
opening for you guys like if you were
never a skeptic if you never thought
about this maybe the wheels are turning
if you had heard about it but thought it
was nonsense of course we went to the
moon I pray that something shown here
was like H maybe I need to look into
this more if it does make you think you
need to look into this more please go
check out a Funny Thing Happened on the
Way to the Moon somehow miraculously
it's not censored by YouTube it's still
on YouTube you can also go to sell.com S
ibr l.com and watch it on his website
but I just thank you guys for being here
I love talking about these topics the
truth will set you free that's what
we're here for the candid truth we want
to talk about the truth and we want to
get candid with it I hope you guys enjoy
this if you did please give it a thumbs
up it really helps get this video out
into the algorithm so more people can
see it if you've never
subscribed to this Channel please take a
moment and hit that little subscribe
button press the little bell icon so you
won't miss another episode like this and
if you would like to donate to this
ministry we have ways of doing that
through cash app vinmo zel if you go to
candid truth.org you can click the
Donate button and donate through PayPal
and it's because of you guys that we can
even continue to do this ministry and
because of that we'll see you next time
I love you guys God bless